[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture si je parle tout
bas c'est normal un concert est en cours
à la maison des associations des loges
en josas pour le festival les baladine
automnale mais avant de parler de cela
voici le sommaire
la troisième édition du festival de
musique classique les baladine automnale
aura lieu du 18 septembre au 2 octobre
sur la communauté d'agglomération de
versailles grand parc nous avons
rencontré la responsable qui nous
parlera de ce festival la nuit blanche
revient samedi 2 octobre 2021 dans les
yvelines au programme de nombreux
évènements nocturnes et gratuit nous
vous donnerons notre top 3 et puis enfin
nous vous présenterons saint germes en
live le nouveau festival de la ville de
saint germain en laye qui aura lieu du 5
au 10 octobre nous sommes à la maison
des associations des loges en josas pour
le festival les baladine automnale un
festival de musique classique
jocelyne lucas a fait part bonjour à toi
p alors est ce que vous êtes donc l'une
des responsables de 3,3 responsables
sont faibles sommes trois musiciens
voilà et nous avec lesquels je travaille
depuis quelques années j'ai fait des
concerts avec eux donc il y à franck
masquelier qui est flûtiste
céline mata ki et harpiste et puis moi
jocelyne lucas donc chanteuse soprano
lyrique voilà alors est-ce que peut-être
nous présenter ce que si ce festival des
maladies l'automnale alors ce festival
des baladins automnale il est né il ya
trois ans c'est pas donc nous avons
comme nous nous travaillons souvent
ensemble nous avons décidé de monter un
festival sur la communauté
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
parce qu'il y avait pas mal de ceux sur
le département mais pas mais pas sur vgp
donc on a commencé un petit peu aller
voir les les villages les maires des
communes etc et puis nous sommes nous
sommes nous avons démarré avec plusieurs
communes dont noisy-le-roi la
celle-saint-cloud
jouer en josas rennes moulin on a essayé
de trouver des lieux parfois atypiques
par exemple cette année à noisy le roi
on va il va y avoir un concert de
guitare avec aux anciennes écuries ont
samedi dernier par exemple on a fait un
cancer alors c'était aussi dans le cadre
des journées européennes du patrimoine
au lavoir de buc là c'est le deuxième la
deuxième date donc aux loges en josas ce
week-end il ya aussi un autre concert
donc à noisy-le-roi donc de guitare
classique sur la musique latine avec
ludovic michel puis le 2 le 2 octobre
parce que c'est moi le dernier jour du
festival c'est à la bibliothèque
de fontenay-le-fleury
et là c'est un trio avec harpe alto et
flûtes avec de la musique debussy ravel
et ce programme est intitulé
l'invitation au voyage et dans ce
programme il y a donc franck masquelier
céline matin qui joue d'accord mais très
bien c'est un programme riche en tout
cas
c'est la troisième édition a fait de bon
la troisième édition la deuxième édition
c'était un peu compliqué parce qu'en
fait on a fait une version numérique du
festival
et donc on a quand même eu toujours le
soutien du département de la spedidam de
versailles grand parc des rats et on a
pu faire une version numérique donc on a
enregistré une partie des spectacles
dans différents lieux qu'ils ont bien
voulu nous accueillir et on les a
diffusés comme ça sur internet et
notamment j'avais fait broadway une
partie de breuillet mais juste en duo
avec avec raphaël aux dates au piano et
donc là ce soir c'est broadway et c'est
ça c'est ça effectivement c'est broadway
est d'ailleurs léger j'ai cru comprendre
qu'à broadway broadway même à new york
ça reprenait aujourd'hui en tout cas
toutes les répétitions les théâtres vont
réouvrir etc donc c'est marrant parce
que c'est une coïncidence un tournoi
c'est un pur hasard donc là on a un
programme de comédies musicales mais pas
que on est un petit peu élargie
d'ailleurs c'est raphaël qui m'a qui m'a
suggéré certains morceaux sur lesquels
on pouvait on pouvait aller un petit peu
parce que lui il est plutôt c'est un
mille 1 1 kg à nice jazz on va dire eh
bien justement vous parlez de broadway
mais regardez ce reportage qui est
justement sur ce concert
[Musique]
ils forment le trio broadway depuis
trois ans à la maison des associations
des loges en josas un pianiste une
chanteuse et un violoniste bassiste joue
des reprises de comédie musicale c'est
un peu hybride ins et piano chant
d'accord avec le violon donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai rajouté la basse parce que
ça permet de rentrer un peu dedans
différemment quoi le trio broadway
reprend bien sûr des chansons du
répertoire des comédies musicales de
broadway comme west side story ou encore
my fair lady
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'interprète également de la musique
plus populaire un peu jazzy fier
[Musique]
il ya notamment du michel legrand la
chanson de maxence qui est dans le film
les demoiselles de rochefort donc voilà
ça s'apparente à la comédie musicale
mais c'est quelque chose de français que
les américains sont réappropriés parce
qu'il ya toujours un peu un échange
culturel qui ce fait il a dû henri
salvador il ya du barbara mais le trio
broadway quasiment familiale puisque
raphaël le pianiste est le fils de
daniel le violoniste une complicité qui
se voit sur la scène le concert a duré
une heure et demie j'ai trouvé ce
spectacle original
très beau c'était super super bien moi
je suis jamais venu mais franchement
c'est à découvrir le pianiste ses
improvisations sont bluffantes la voile
la choriste aussi donc puis j'aime
beaucoup aussi la basse une centaine de
personnes étaient venues assister à ce
concert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors justin lucas on vient de voir le
sujet finalement pour reproduire ce
genre de concert c'est beaucoup de
préparation non oui pas mal
effectivement il ya déjà tout un travail
en amont de savoir comment
finalement le contenu du programme léger
avant de travailler de programme il faut
le contenu du programme un petit peu un
fil conducteur etc et donc on a beaucoup
on a beaucoup échangé avec raphaël
daniel un petit peu pour savoir ce qu'on
ce qu'on voulait les uns c'est disons
par exemple raphaël avait envie de jouer
et d'aller un peu vers autre chose moi
je n'étais un petit peu le vraiment
fermé sur la comédie musicale mais on
est un petit peu ouvert sur d'autres
points puis on a on a on avait déjà fait
ce programme et on l'avait pas on avait
ça on avait fait ça de manière comme un
comme un récital et puis on s'est dit
daniel d'atomes a suggéré de prendre 1
il a un ami un comédien qui fait
beaucoup de mise en scène et du coup on
s'est vu quelquefois moi j'avais écrit
un fil conducteur enfin un texte un
petit peu pour faire un lien entre les
morceaux et puis il a pris ça et puis
avec ça on a fait une petite mise en
espace on va dire un petit peu pour
qu'ils aient un peu plus de complicité
aussi entre entre nous trois d'accord
voilà merci beaucoup je suis garé là var
était notre invité mais oui merci une
autre idée de sortie à présent samedi 2
octobre c'est la nuit blanche en
ile-de-france dans les éviers de
plusieurs d'établissements proposent
d'ouvrir en nocturne et gratuitement
leurs portes voici notre top 3
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
ou
encore graveur la 17e édition de
parcours d'artiste revient en vallée de
chevreuse 97 eur artistes vous attendent
dans leur atelier les deux et trois et
les 9 et 10 octobre prochains michel
khoury un membre de l'association nous
en parle on est plus de 100 artistes qui
sont j'ai vu qu'ils sont tous basés
autour de la vallée de chevreuse autour
du parc et dans les villes les villes
alentour alors il ya des artistes de
tous secteurs un des plasticiens des
fans et des pannes des sculpteurs il ya
toutes les catégories des arts
plastiques mais il ya aussi des
musiciens des gens qui font du théâtre
des gens qui écrivent les artistes
peuvent exposer chez eux dans leurs
ateliers ou dans des lieux
où on expose à plusieurs ça peut être
des lieux historiques des prix y aurait
des
des lavoirs
des chapelles la ville de stains germans
les organismes de son nouveau festival
sans jamais en live accueillera de
nombreux artistes des spectacles
gratuits seront également proposés on
écoute benoît dissaux le directeur
artistique du festival
[Musique]
c'est un festival dont qui se veut
différent de ce qui se passait
auparavant à saint germain une volonté
politique de créer un nouvel événement à
dominante musicale en essayant de
balayer un peu toutes les esthétiques
musicales qui existent donc on c'est un
festival de musiques actuelles
[Musique]
on a allié
toutes les esthétiques de la musique pop
électro rap jazz chanson française
est aussi un maillage entre des têtes
d'affiché et aussi les découvertes et
être encore malade
l'impératrice
gaëtan roussel et fatoumata diawara
voilà on a on a quatre quand même grosse
tête d'affiche
c'est la volonté politique de vouloir en
faire un événement majeur de début de
saison pour la ville de saint germain
uniquement donc c'est pourquoi aînés
saint germain en live pour essayer puis
en essayant de développer davantage
peut-être la formation comme je vous le
disais en ouverture un peu sur
l'international
[Musique]
m
et c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yvelinois bonne soirée sur tvt
à 118
[Musique]